Good to see though,
man.
What's up?
Good to be here and talk.
Hunter Thompson.
My my pleasure.
Um,
so your book free kingdom,
you know,
we live in interesting times right now.
It's kind of a kind of a shit show at every campus in a moment.
About a fist from your face.
Pull that sucker.
My hands.
Should I put them up and do whatever you want with your hands.
Shoot with this one,
what is all this a,
you had a lot of writing.
Well,
when I wrote the book I wanted to make sure my sentence never sounded like
Thompson sentences,
so I didn't write out a lot of his sentences.
But this morning before coming on I went and got some of my favorite quotes from
just word of out long handed to get a sense of what is a,
what his perspective was when rhythm.
Once again,
didn't he do that with the Great Gatsby?
He like a few times by hand.
He like typed it out.
Yeah.
I love that idea that he was trying to find like the rhythm of the words.
That's such a fascinating notion because comedians do that in the early days of
comedy,
like a lot of guys,
um,
in like before they ever start getting on stage themselves,
they'll imitate their favorite comedians,
bits.
Like they'll do a Richard Pryor bit and they'll do it to their friends and
they'll get,
get a sense of the rhythm and the timing and get those laughs from doing a
Richard Pryor bit to their friends.
And then they get that bug.
It's like part of what infects them.
I mean,
that's the hardest thing to steal.
We're not plagiarizing,
but we're trying to understand what decisions they made.
Beautiful work.
Yeah.
I'm sure he wasn't plagiarizing,
but it's,
it's so unfortunate when,
when someone does.
Yes.
You know,
when,
when you have someone,
whether it's a hunter or Richard Pryor or anyone who's just got a truly
exceptional and unique mind or someone who doesn't like our president and
decided when he ran in 2016 to plagiarize Richard Nixon's 1968 convention speech
speeches directly.
Really?
Yeah.
That was the headlight and the fucking times it said Nixon's inspiration.
I'm sorry.
Uh,
Trump's inspiration.
Nixon is the one.
So the light's about crime in,
um,
like barbarians at the gate,
crime,
law and order.
Those were all from Nixon's Shitty but successful in 1968,
a Miami convention speech and Thompson,
you know,
Thompson knew how effective that that was.
Yeah.
I wonder if he did that on purpose because he was so good in one thing that
Trump is so good at it.
He's so good at getting the media to talk about him.
And like,
one of the best ways to get the media to talk about him was give them something
to be angry about that no one else is going to give a fuck about.
He was like,
oh,
well Anya plagiarize,
but I plagiarize much better from Nixon.
I loved it.
And Melania took some lines from Michelle Obama's speech,
right?
Yeah.
If you plagiarize Nixon,
that's okay.
All right.
So freaking dumb.
The book about Hunter s Thompson.
I mean it's really about taking the fucking emotion of living in this present,
looking back at Thompson's career and then trying to write,
um,
it like a novel to dramatize all of the experiences he went through that art
today so applicable to us and just show his perspective that's so applicable to
us today.
What do you got here,
Jamie,
from New York Times?
Donald Trump's going to finish anybody inspiration and Nixon,
I was like,
are you,
you're running on Nixon,
that's what you're running on.
Here's some parallels,
you know,
I mean,
do you remember when,
um,
when hunter got together with a Bill Murray and bill's brother and they did that
thing where they were trying to get people to a,
Nixon got a bad deal.
We've got to bring them back and people were going along with it.
Oh yeah.
That's good.
Yeah.
Yeah,
I remember that like that.
There's a lot of parallels with Trump in that regard.
I mean,
one of my favorite quotes by Thompson is like,
um,
you know,
Richard Nixon is with this Barbie doll family and his Barbie doll wife is like
America's answer to um,
you know,
it's America's doctor Jekyll and Mr. Hyde and like,
he is the Werewolf.
He speaks to the Werewolf in us and Nixon chose to hide that Werewolf his whole
career until it finally came out cause he was insane with power.
Trump ran on the werewolf.
He's like,
no,
I'm not going to hide it.
That's who I am.
That's what I'm going to use to try to get elected.
And like George Wallace did,
like other politicians did.
It had resonance and it happened with Trump because of our media environment,
because of the place we live in now to amplify them all the way to the most
powerful position in the world,
which is insane.
It would be really fascinating to see if hunter was alive and in his prime.
Now how he,
I think his take on that were very similar to Matt Tie EBS,
you know like mad tie Eeb is in my opinion,
our more reasonable,
more put together version of Hunter Thompson.
Yeah.
Cause he's more stained discipline,
long career for each of the pathologies like rational and he's there all the
time.
Like the,
I'm sure you've heard the recently uncovered recording of hunter calling in to
some company that installed a DVD player and he's fucking screaming and yell at,
it's like 15 minutes long and then he like gets lost.
I think that's what the fuck and the DVD player doesn't work.
Y'All got y'all my fucking cards.
I mean that was in the 1980s were not the best.
You know,
I think what Toby does is what Thompson did very well on.
It was really good at looking at Nixon saying,
how are you manipulating the way we see you?
You get a version of you out and Toby looks at the way the media gets played.
He looks at the way that an administration manipulates the media and he
dramatizes that while everybody else just gives us the information the
administration is giving us.
And that goes back to Thompson with Nixon.
Thomson had space when he worked for rolling stone and he could write about how
Nixon made everybody watch his speeches,
the press on a closed circuit television and they made the press just like Trump
off in the corner when the plane arrived,
you know,
being berated by everybody.
It's very similar to what is going on now.
And again,
we see people getting hot takes are we see people doing eds.
We don't see people dramatizing how manipulative these corrupt administrations
are.
And were,
and Thompson did that beautifully Tybee does that be a play?
Was a Nixon being berated by the press?
Is that why he chose to have thought it was,
I mean he was a crook so he doesn't want the press to investigate them.
Like he,
you know,
he was a cricket with San Clemente,
like his loans with Bibi rebozo and all of that.
He was a curriculum.
They use the IRS to investigate his,
and it needs,
he was a crook when he tried to break into the Brookings Institution to destroy
and fom evidence.
He didn't want the press around him because he had committed very serious crimes
that I think that's similar to what we see now.
I mean,
as people sit on the show,
no,
no president wants the a journalist,
you know,
digging into their lives specifically because you don't want chumminess with
journalists.
But I think Trump and Nixon both knew they had so much to hide that to actually
have a journalist like Hunter Thompson who was a good investigative journalist,
to have the most like my TV around,
that's dangerous for them.
They'll go to jail,
which Nixon should have Trump perhaps should,
while who knows what's going to happen.
How did you,
uh,
how'd you get involved with a writing this book?
Well,
I mean,
I've always loved on her assumption in I was,
you get exposed to them,
you know,
in,
uh,
I was 17 years old in a Catholic high school at Bellarmine college preparatory
up in San Jose and we had a counterculture,
a writing class.
And so I read some of it in there.
And then a friend had an audio book,
the fear and loathing.
And so I just remember the first time hearing that old audio book of fear and
Lillian where somewhere around Barstow on the edge of the desert.
And then in my twenties I really got into strange rumblings and [inaudible],
which is about a conspiracy within the Los Angeles Police Department.
Um,
regarding the death of Ruben Salazar.
I'm a prominent journalist and I read that,
I'm like,
oh my God,
dude,
this isn't somebody that's just dancing on stage or like performing a road
narrative.
This is an investigative journalist who's going to the most powerful people
exposing things they don't want us to see and in a sense of risking his life to
do so.
Because he says in strange rumblings in Oslo long,
which has in rolling stone in 1970 he says that they're willing to kill Ruben
Salazar who was the most prominent journalist in Los Angeles.
You could argue at the time what the fuck is to stop them from killing me.
Hunter Thompson for asking these questions.
Well I think that's what a lot of people were saying today with Jamil Cause
Shogi,
you know,
Jamal could show his death has got a lot of journalists really freaking out.
Like what,
you know,
what am I doing if I'm criticizing world leaders,
talking about international politics,
if this could happen to me,
political violence is effective because it's used to silence either opposition
or journalists.
And so for me,
writing this book and I tried to dramatize it like a novel,
it's quick,
it's like only 200 2,210 pages and then it's like a hundred pages of notes.
So I like cited every site smeller sound so that somebody that knows Thompson
really well,
it can be like,
where the fuck did you get this information right?
And somebody else can if they have questions,
just go back and look.
But long story short for me,
the crux of the book,
um,
was in Chicago in 1968 where a hundred Thompson at a press pass,
he went to the Democratic National Convention on Wednesday night.
Mayor Daley gave this order to clear the intersection of Balbo in Michigan
because there is a protest going on.
Five,
10,000 people.
Thompson was standing next to the Haymarket in which was on the ground floor
level.
It was a plate glass window.
He was standing with delegates from the Democratic National Convention standing
what there was and the cops have charged,
they did like a double pincher formation like Hannibal and like um,
Qubein like fucking 100 BC and they split the protesters and half beat.
Everybody hit Thompson over the head.
He got his motorcycle helmet on just in time.
So he's not cussed.
He can see everything that's going on and the entire plate glass window behind
him shatters.
Everybody falls in,
cops jump in,
are beating everybody and he's looking around and he's sure that snipers on the
roof are going to open fire at any moment.
So he runs to the Blackstone where he staying across the way shows as RoomKey
gets beat up by the cops is trying to get any.
He goes,
I live here,
goddammit,
I'm paying $100 a day,
let me get my fucking room.
And he barely gets it and he just sits on his bed afterwards and he says they
knew I was pressed.
They saw my press pass,
the hit me because I was pressed.
And if that's where we're at right now with journalists,
you know,
political opponents and journalists are being clubbed to keep silent and to not
respond then this is not the democracy.
We know.
Yeah.
His ex wife talked about that as being like one of the only moments where she
saw him cry for two weeks,
toss,
cried afterwards for two weeks.
He couldn't stop.
It was crazy.
It was a,
it was a crazy time.
Right.
I mean that the time is very similar in a lot of ways to what's going on today.
It's just today there's just so much more information and so much more.
People have so much more of an ability to communicate.
Yeah.
And I think it's almost easier to coordinate violence.
I was just talking to the head of the proud boys.
You know,
Gavin McInnes is a group,
um,
Enrique [inaudible] and he's like,
you know,
he's an advocate.
He's saying he's using the language of the left.
He's like,
I'm a victim.
I can't buy groceries.
They'd taken my big accounts,
my platforms.
But when he talks about violence,
he's like,
who the fuck are you?
Antifa like I'm,
you know,
you're 120 pounds in wet.
Like if we have civil war,
you're going to lose.
And I was sitting next to him for the podcast and basically what I said was,
if we have a civil war,
you're going to be hit by sniper fire from the fucking roof.
You're not going to be at a fist fight when antifa across the way.
And I think there's this idea on the right that we can push towards violence and
we can get very close to it with our rhetoric or with our,
um,
actions,
but that it won't spread.
Like the conflagration won't keep going.
Yeah.
I don't know if that's how I slid it to the right.
I mean,
not with Antifa on the left too.
And that's why I love Thompson was as hard on the left as he was on the right
when he wrote.
And it was so important for his intelligence as a writer.
But I think just even the left and the right in general for a lot of these
people is just an identity and a gang that they belong to.
And I don't think they really understand violence.
You know,
you want to talk about violence,
talk to a military guy,
you know,
talk to someone who really understands what violence actually is and they don't
have this empty rhetoric like these fools do.
Exactly.
So a lot of these people that are calling for violence,
like,
no,
you should be calling for camaraderie and you should be calling for
communication.
We should be calling for some way.
We could all work this out where the civilians,
the s,
the civilization that we live in,
that we all,
we all can get along together and most people don't want to impede you from
living your life and doing what you want to do.
Most people,
the vast majority a hundred drums of believed in working within the system.
He knew,
he believed like it might be a fucked up system,
but you can still run for sheriff and Aspen and he believe once you resort to
violence,
that means the conversation has stopped and it disfigures you.
So he cried for two weeks.
That was the most surprising thing for me researching this book and writing it
was to see how much the violence affected him that he experienced at Chicago.
You can speak to someone who's done and then may fighting has been punched in
the face as hard as somebody can punch you.
Most Americans haven't had that and that changes your ability to articulate
something back in that moment.
It means if that's political,
if it's a police officer or a political opponent that uses violence instead of
an argument to respond to you,
we've,
we've left the realm that we recognize and we're not going to be able to
communicate even in the limited way that we're communicating right now at
Thompson knew that.
So that's why after Chicago,
I love that he went back to aspen and he's like,
I'm going to run the fucking sheriff and you want to run.
I'm going to do a mayoral campaign and Aspen.
And that was brilliant because it was his way to control his environment,
knowing that Mayor Daley's not listening to his nonviolent protest.
Richard Nixon is not listening to his nonviolent protest.
Thompson needed to find another avenue to try to work within the American system
to make things happen.
And the great contrast is his good friend Oscar Zeta Acosta.
There's a wonderful PBS documentary at rise and fall,
the Brown Buffalo by,
I'm Phillip.
Puerto is a great director and it's a cost his life.
That's who Dr Gonzo is based on shore in the,
you know,
Thompson had more advantages than Acosta and Acosta was being pursued by the
LAPD was eventually set up by them and for him working within the system,
he ran for sheriff,
it wasn't an option.
The Cobb set him up for a high speed bust,
you know,
like the cops had,
the cubs had undercover agents from something called the special operations for
conspiracy,
which is a fucking department and the LAPD at the time.
And they were trying to use those provocateurs to incite violence against the
plainclothes please.
So that or the normal cost police so that lethal violence could be used to
silence us civil rights movement in the Brown bread.
So they used agent provocateurs to make it look like they're a part of the
protest.
Yeah,
there was an age old tactic,
right.
That's how you destroy a civil rights movement.
Because the most effective weapon in silencing civil rights is lethal force.
And you can do that in another country as the US has done.
But you must can't use tactics like Mo,
my lie,
like Thompson writes about this in the US,
unless you have a provocative reason,
unless somebody that's undercover attacks a cop.
And so the cops then like what happened on August 29th,
1978 during the moratorium,
riots can just flood east la whoever they want and it can,
the blue ribbons,
haulers art's head off with a tear gas gun.